GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
YOU JUST HEARD FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
RIGHT NOW, THOUGH, WE HAVE A
RARE FIRSTHAND ACCOUNT FROM THE
CENTER OF MAYBE THE GREATEST
SCANDAL IN MODERN POLITICAL
HISTORY, THE FBI SPYING ON THE
2016 TRUMP CAMPAIGN FOR NEARLY
TWO YEARS.
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
AND THEIR DO YOU TELLIFUL
LACKEYS IN THE PRESS DENIED THAT
HAPPENED.
NOW WE DO KNOW THAT IT HAPPENED.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION USED
GOVERNMENT AGENCY TO SURVEY A
RIVAL CAMPAIGN.
THERE'S NO DENYING THAT.
SO INSTEAD THE USUAL APOLOGISTS
ARE CLAIMING IT WAS A GOOD
THING, IN FACT, SPYING ON TRUMP
TO PROTECT HIM.
BY THE WAY, YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
EVEN ASKING QUESTIONS, A SIGN OF
DISLOYALTY, SHUT UP AND OBEY.
NO THANKS.
TONIGHT WE HAVE A DIRECT ACCOUNT
OF WHAT HAPPENED, THE FIRST FULL
INTERVIEW WITH A TRUMP CAMPAIGN
OFFICIAL APPARENTLY TARGETED BY
AN FBI SPY.
TIM CLOVIS WAS A FORMER NATIONAL
CO-CHAIRMAN OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
IN 2016, HE HAD A FACE-TO-FACE
MEETING WITH A MAN BELIEVED TO
BE WITH ONE OF THE FBI SPIES ON
THAT CAMPAIGN.
SAM CLOVIS JOINS US.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
>> YOU BELIEVE YOU HAD A
FACE-TO-FACE ENCOUNTER.
DESCRIBE THAT MEETING.
>> SEVERAL DAYS BEFORE THE
SEPTEMBER 1st MEETING I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE EMAILS
FROM STEVEN HALPER, SAYING HE
KNEW CARTER PAGE, AND ASKED FOR
A SIT-DOWN WITH ME.
HE WANTED TO COME IN AND DISCUSS
FOREIGN POLICY AND TO PROVIDE
SOME -- WHAT HE THOUGHT MIGHT BE
HIS -- SOME OF HIS WRITINGS THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE,
HELP US, IN THE CAMPAIGN.
I ARRANGED THAT MEETING.
WE HAD THAT MEETING IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. ON THE 1st OF
SEPTEMBER.
IT LASTED ABOUT AN HOUR.
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
OVER COFFEE WITH HIM HIS
RESEARCH, AND IT WAS MOSTLY
FOCUSED ON CHINA.
THEN I THINK AFTER THAT MEETING,
AND THEN ON THE 27th OF
SEPTEMBER I RECEIVED AN EMAIL
FROM HIM WITH SEVERAL
ATTACHMENTS.
I CAN BE HONEST WITH YOU,
TUCKER, I HAVEN'T EVEN OPENED
THOSE ATTACHMENTS TO THIS DAY.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT WAS IN THEM,
BUT MOSTLY PAPERS TITLED THAT
DEALT WITH CHINA.
I THINK HE USED MY MEETING AS
A -- USING MY MEETING AS A BONA
FIDE WITH GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS,
TO HAVE A MEETING WITH HIM, THAT
I DID NOT KNOW ABOUT, THAT WAS
SUBSEQUENT TO MY MEETING WITH
HIM ON THE 1st OF SEPTEMBER.
>> SO YOU DIDN'T KNOW HIM
BEFORE?
HE EMAILED YOU COLD?
>> NO, I DID NOT.
I JUST GOT THE EMAIL THAT ASKED
FOR THE MEETING, AND HE USED THE
FACT THAT HE KNEW CARTER PAGE.
>> RIGHT.
>> OF COURSE CARTER HAD BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH OUR CAMPAIGN.
>> AT WHAT POINT DID YOU BEGIN
TO SUSPECT HE WAS WORKING FOR
THE FBI, SEEKING TO GATHER
INFORMATION SURREPTITIOUSLY ON
THE CAMPAIGN?
>> WELL, OUR MEETING WAS LIKE
TWO FACULTY MEMBERS IN THE
FACULTY LOUNGE.
I DIDN'T THINK ANY OF IT UNTIL I
STARTED TO SEE THE REPORTING
THAT CAME OUT RECENTLY.
THEN I STARTED TO PUT TWO AND
TWO TOGETHER.
THEN IT MADE SENSE TO ME THAT HE
WAS PROBING TO FIND A WEAK SPOT
IN OUR CAMPAIGN, SOMEONE WHO
MIGHT BE VULNERABLE TO
CONNECTING THINGS BACK TO THOSE
ELUSIVE 30,000 EMAILS THAT
SUPPOSEDLY THE RUSSIANS HAD.
I REALLY THINK THAT'S WHAT HIS
TASK WAS, WAS TO CREATE AN AUDIT
TRAIL BACK TO THOSE EMAILS FROM
SOMEONE IN THE CAMPAIGN OR
SOMEONE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CAMPAIGN SO THAT THEY COULD
DEVELOP A STRONGER CASE FOR
PROBABLE CAUSE TO CONTINUE TO
ISSUE WARRANTS AND TO FURTHER AN
INVESTIGATION.
I REALLY FELT AFTER HEARING ALL
OF THESE OTHER THINGS, LISTENING
TO THE REPORTS THAT I'VE READ,
THAT THIS TRULY WAS AN EFFORT TO
BUILD SOMETHING THAT DID NOT
EXIST.
I REALLY THINK THAT WAS WHAT HIS
MISSION WAS.
>> WHY HAVEN'T YOU READ THE
ATTACHMENTS TO HIS EMAILS?
>> WELL, ONE, I WAS BUSY.
I WORKED 16-20 HOURS A DAY.
WE ALREADY HAD A LOT OF HELP ON
FOREIGN POLICY IN AREAS OF
CHINA.
I REALLY DIDN'T THINK THEY WERE
GOING TO CONTRIBUTE TO ANYTHING.
FRANKLY, I'VE GONE BACK AND
REVIEWED ALL MY EMAILS.
I DIDN'T REPORT THAT MEETING TO
ANYONE IN THE CAMPAIGN, SO THE
MEETING WAS OF NO CONSEQUENCE TO
ME AS FAR AS ANYTHING YOU COULD
REMEMBER.
I'VE LOOKED THROUGH ALL OF MY
PERSONAL EMAILS, EVERYTHING, AND
I CAN'T FIND A RECORD OF IT AT
ALL.
>> INTERESTING.
THAT MEETING MAY HAVE PLAYED A
KEY ROLE IN A MUCH LARGER STORY.
SAM, THANK YOU FOR THAT ACCOUNT.